now if you want to exit your job more
gracefully listen up a record four and a
half million americans quit their jobs
in november and a recent linkedin survey
shows the great resignation will likely
continue 62 percent of working americans
said that they are considering a job
change in 2022 with 24
looking right now linkedin career expert
catherine fisher joins us right now how
are you doing this morning thanks for
having me so why are so many people
quitting their jobs well there's a lot
of jobs out there to be had and what's
happened is over the last couple of
years people have really you know sat
down and thought to themselves does my
job match my values is this giving me
what i need out of my life
you combine that with the record number
of jobs available plus now we're you
know well with amacrom it's a little
different but with the pandemic you know
people now are feeling more comfortable
to make a change so whereas you saw
people sheltering in place and that
included their jobs they're now more
willing to go out there and make a
change i was raised in the the mantra
that you don't quit a job without a job
and i remember saying to my son who was
unhappy at the time don't quit a job
without a job he didn't listen to me and
quit and said i'll just figure it out
but do you think that that do you think
that that more people are thinking that
way they're quitting and they don't even
have another job is that okay to do i
think obviously it does depend on
personal circumstances it's okay if
you're if you're in a position that you
can wait a little while to get the right
job what you don't want to do is then be
forced to like jump into the wrong job
and make the mistakes that you've made
if you can afford to sit yes and the
good news though is because there are so
many job openings you'll likely get one
pretty quickly but it's important to
really take stock of what's important to
you what values and then match up the
companies that really align with your
values as opposed to like i'm just going
to get the first job that i can do
employees have the upper hand these days
do you think i do think so and i think
what you're also seeing is that the
employers companies are really taking a
look at not only do i how do i get
people to come join the company because
we have all these job openings how do i
get them to stay
so it's become a culture of more
human-centric and if you see like we
just released our jobs on the rise and a
lot of the jobs that are you know rising
to the top are ones that are really
indicate that companies are looking for
this so diversity inclusion managers
chief
hr officers and the talent acquisition
specialist so they're starting to really
invest in those these are jobs with
college degrees involved
yes generally speaking but there are
also like in logistics which is we see
is an industry that is hiring a lot and
what's great about that
is that they offer training and they pay
well so this is an area where people who
are shifting industries maybe they don't
want to be burned by the hospitality
industry i do want to deliver on the
promise of that jerry maguire clip how
should one
gracefully exit a job they no longer
want to be in yes you have to keep in
mind that the relationships that you've
built during your career and at that job
are going to carry you through your job
so that is walk out singing take this
job and shove it is that good i would
not do that that is not good advice and
so you really want to you know leave a
job just as you joined it gracefully and
with the intention to build and maintain
those relationships and let make sure
your boss is the first to know give
adequate you know notice with the demand
for um
jobs that require you to work from home
or allow you to work from home which
states are hiring well we're seeing a
lot of interest in denver and cleveland
and austin and some of this could be
because you're seeing some you know tech
companies build hubs there also we're
seeing a rise in entrepreneurship
and you know some people are saying
listen i can work and live where i want
to so i'm going to go to a place that
maybe is a little bit more affordable
and gives me the quality of life that
i'm looking for so somebody listening to
you right now catherine's going you know
i really don't like my job i don't like
the people i work with i really want to
make a change what are the steps they
should do
they should figure out what is it that
they don't like about their job and
before just jumping ship talk to your
manager and say this is what i need from
my job and the company are you able to
deliver this if the answer is no start
looking but again look more for the
companies in their culture because right
now those companies are focusing on
culture a lot of people have that
resignation letter already in the drafts
tony's just just waiting to pull it out
now
thank you very much we appreciate it